[Music]
in a world of wall-to-wall CGI where
practical action is a thing of the past
a masterpiece of handcrafted death and
destruction will rise from the director
of happy feet and babe pig in the city
wait what
that'll do a pig that'll do Mad Max fury
road when a brutal patriarchy oppresses
his people the one woman will rise
against him and steal the brides who
refuse to be his property as this badass
sharpshooting truck driver races across
the desert to freedom and liberate the
tortured human livestock from his
oppressive rule oh and there's a guy
named Max in the two pitas kind of hangs
out Tom Hardy kind of stars as Mad Max
the role Mel Gibson got too mad to play
he's a man a few words wanna focus no
you do but many grunge
who spends most of the film being
chained the various things together
they'll embark on a two-hour game of
Mario Kart from hell as a two-hour chase
scene unfolds when they dare to turn
left
then drive across the desert
then turn around and drive back the way
they came going back okay it's a little
short um plot but who cares well the
action looks like this I mean are you
kidding me with that shot or if that one
or that one witness this wou journey to
a wasteland full of robot arms flame
guitars and Giant Killer monster trucks
where Humanity is running short on fuel
and water but everyone goes out of their
way to drive an impractical gas guzzler
and everyone wastes a ton of water there
has got to be a more efficient way to
distribute that turn off the hose at
least put a bucket down or something so
strapped in with this summers only hard
our movie made by a grandpa that makes
every other summer franchise look tame
by comparison
age of Ultron Jurassic world and
Terminator Genisys
[Music]
starring Tom hardly in the movie fast
and furios
about a war boy bein with a sleep apnea
machine
Eric the actor powders Real Housewives
of the Citadel you will never be this
metal and darude-sandstorm Mad Max road
trip let's be honest the real winners
and all of this are the people who make
superfood mist
oh what a spray what a lovely spray
that's the taste aerbook be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers you
will arrive at the gates of Valhalla
shiny and chrome it feels like I'm
wearing nothing at all nothing at all
nothing at all who's your friend that
likes to play Bing bong Bing bong die
potato Evil Dead 3 army of dragna's I
liked Fantastic Four no I didn't